one of the best predictors for
pathological Pawn use is the age at
which you first become exposed to it why
how does porn use impact the developing
brain what is it about this which
direction is the arrow of causation
going in yeah so so a couple of caveats
about that so that's like a observation
we've made of people in our community I
don't know if there's actually research
on that but I wouldn't be surprised if
there was yeah that's true of all the
other addictions okay so we sort of know
why and so we know that when you have a
developing brain adding a substance to
it makes us more vulnerable to it long
term so there's even studies that show
that
early marijuana usage
leads is more likely to lead to
addictions of other kinds and it's
because when you use marijuana at a
young age it actually Alters how your
dopamine circuitry is formed
and leaves you vulnerable to other
addictions so my guess is that
pornography has some similar
neuroscientific mechanism where
something is going on where even if
you're because these people are
prepubescent usually when they're
exposed which means that they don't get
aroused
like usually right so so and they don't
even understand what they're seeing
which is the most common thing when I
talk to people who are addicted to
pornography most common thing is I was
like seven
and my 15 year old brother like showed
me this thing and him and his friends
were watching it and it was super cool I
didn't understand what was going on
but we do know that adding stuff to the
developing brain whether it's a
particular kind of stimulus let's say
like abuse appearance right so that's
not a substance or a substance Alters
its formation
and that those effects are let's say not
quite permanent but sticky
and then require some time to be rewired
and so probably it has something to do
with the way that our dopamine circuitry
our emotional circuitry
those things kind of get laid down with
that perfectly shows why porn use is at
least in part not sexual
because you have you have this coping
mechanism for an individual who is as
yet not sexual
and and that I think is the the weirdest
thing for pornography addiction is that
like a lot of it honestly in my clinical
experience is like not very sexual in
nature it's really about some weird
emotional suppression you know mentally
checking out getting that Spurt of
relief
um and and that's also why you'll you'll
see so much usage it's not like people
are they feel compulsions as opposed to
feeling horny yeah then we're just not
aroused for eight hours straight right
it's not like you know we're gonna
jerk off all day and it's gonna be great
it's like I feel terrible about myself I
don't know what to do I feel a
compulsion to watch the stuff do this
thing for a while if I get into a fight
I need to do it again I'm
procrastinating I've wasted the whole
day I feel ashamed of myself because
I've done this for the last four hours I
need to do it again that's honestly more
of what it is
I think that taking it out of the realm
of sex which you know the world still
has massive problems talking about
openly it's something that's kind of
very shameful and guilt-ridden and
private and all the rest of it taking it
out of that and just saying luck man for
you it's fapping for the girl that lives
next door it's binge eating the guy that
lives down the street it's video games
for the dude that lives next door to you
it's marijuana
coping mechanisms all the way down yeah
I think that takes away a lot of the
shame which is pretty cool one of the
other
um considerations that I imagine must
happen an awful lot is around bedtime
routines sleep sleep hygiene generally
from your community if you're talking
about people that use screams an awful
lot people that use social media porn
Video Games
Etc why is it
that we get so motivated in the middle
of the night instead of first thing in
the morning why did nature decide that
it was going to curse us so that our
brains can't shut off when we're about
to go to sleep and yet when we want to
wake up first thing in the morning our
brains don't want to start so I think
there are a lot of different answers to
this
um I think a big part of it is that
so a big part of what we do if we look
at the staring at a wall exercise for
example
so a lot of that real solid positive
motivation comes from within
and if we really look at our society
what's going on right now is we are
being told what we want all the time so
we've lost touch with ourselves right so
like there's a notification oh this game
is coming out there's this new movie
coming out there's a Super Mario movie
there's this movie there's that movie
there's this kind of thing and by the
way there's this kind of thing that you
can do to be healthy you should be
healthy you need to be healthy you need
to be more motivated this is how you
grind this is how you be productive be
all of these things
and so what's happening in our society
is we are gravitating
towards stuff outside of us all the time
and the people are getting better and
better at getting us get getting us
gravitated towards them right so Oreo is
figuring out okay what color can we put
the package you know how can we make it
crinkly like so that you know there's
some kind of pavlovian condition like
everyone's getting better at this
and so oftentimes if you kind of think
about it at night a couple of things
happen the night is the only time you're
with yourself
right and maybe you're and and I
guarantee you the people who are getting
motivated are not sitting there Doom
scrolling on their phone until they pass
out they're usually like sitting down
quietly or something like that like what
happens is you doom scroll you doom
scroll you do scroll you get tired you
put the phone away you put your head on
the pillow you don't fall asleep and
then you start having all these ideas
so it's really the only time that in the
shower right because we haven't we don't
have
we don't have waterproof phones
perfectly yet
so that's why like all these profound
thoughts happen in the shower it's not
like the shower is magical and has some
neurochemical that you're inhaling that
makes you more creative it's the only
time that you have with yourself
and there are studies that show that
meditation improves creativity and
things like that why is that it's
because you're with yourself
so that's one reason
there are a couple of other reasons
though I think that some people have a
different circadian rhythm and their
creative time is really late at night if
you look at basically religions across
the world they sort of have this
convergent evolution of mental work at
like
three to six in the morning so depending
on how late you stay up you may actually
be tapping into that what's in Sanskrit
called Brahma murta is also the time of
like matins so there's like this window
of time that based on circadian rhythm
where your mind is actually very very
active and that's how I ended up
studying two hours in med school I just
studied during brummel work I was like
Hey and everything just sinks in it's
like getting up we're getting up early
or staying at play so we're getting up
early
so I'd wake up at like 4am I'd do like
yoga and meditation I'd study for two
hours and I'd go to class and then I'd
Finish class and I'm done for the day
which is great
um so so I I think that you know you
have to be a little bit careful about
your circadian rhythm that just could be
your time but a lot of it is just that's
the time that you're with yourself
and so gotta just spend more time with
yourself like you're a cool person
you don't need something else to
entertain you we'll get back to talking
to Dr Kane one minute but first I need
to tell you about element I've taken
element every single morning for
probably three years now it is my
favorite way to start the day it tastes
fantastic it optimizes my hydration it
makes my brain work more effectively and
it really wakes me up element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
gluten no colors no artificial
ingredients no fillers and no BS they
are the exclusive hydration partner to
Team USA weightlifting and rely down by
tons of FBI sniper teams Special Forces
Navy Seals and high performers all
around the world it plays a critical
role in reducing muscle cramps and
fatigue whilst optimizing brain health
and regulating your appetite on top of
all of that they've got a no BS no
questions asked refund policy so you can
buy it and if you do not like it for any
reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box that's how confident they are
that you love it head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with your first box
that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace